لقد
كنت رائعًا
في زيادة الوعي حول إساءة معاملة
الأطفال ، أعلم أنك كنت
تتحدث عن ذلك على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ، لقد بدأت هذا الكتاب ، لقد أدهشني حقًا
وصف الاعتداء الجنسي
الذي تعرضت له ،
وأعتقد أن هذا كان  من المهم حقًا
أن أظن أنه عندما تكتب سيرتك الذاتية ،
فالأمر لا يتعلق بنفسك ، بل على وشك
مساعدة الأشخاص الآخرين
الذين تخبرهم بقصتك الكاملة وأتذكر
أنني أعتقد
أن أكثر اللحظات تدميرًا ليست بالنسبة
لي للانفتاح على العالم ، لقد كان الأمر أشبه
بإخباره  أمي لأن هذه الأشياء تحدث
عندما كان عمري 13 عامًا
ولم أقل
أبدًا لأي فرد من عائلتي ولا حتى
أمي ،
لذا حتى عندما أتحدث عن الأمر يكون
دائمًا صعبًا
لأنني أنتظر على الأقل لمدة 25
عامًا لأقول  أمي قبل
إصدار الكتاب ، أقول يا أمي ، سأخبرك فقط
أن هذه الأشياء تحدث ، تعلمون أنني كنت
في باريس ، لقد دمرت وقالت إنه
لا يجب عليك وضعها في كتابك ، أقول
نعم أمي قالت إنه شخصي للغاية  أقول
نعم ولكن أمي لا  بالنسبة
لي ، بالنسبة للأطفال ، لا أريد
أن يعاني الناس بنفس الطريقة التي أعاني بها
،
وأنت تعلم أيضًا عندما تحدث هذه الأشياء ،
فأنت تشعر
بالعار تجاه نفسك ، فأنت تشعر بالذنب ، فأنت
لا تعرف ما إذا كان الناس سيثقون بك
بشكل خاص  عندما كان عمري 24 عامًا كنت
ألعب في موناكو وسألتني الشرطة
عن هذا الشخص وأقول لا ،
لم يفعل شيئًا كذبة ، لذلك كان لدي هذا
الغطاء أيضًا في صدري
حيث شعرت أنه كان جبانًا نعم نعم
وهذا هو  هذا هو السبب في أنني لا أريد
عندما يقول الناس يا فتري ،
أنت شجاع جدًا ، أنت شجاع جدًا للتحدث
بصراحة عن أن الأمر لا يتعلق بأن
الضحية ليس لأنهم ليسوا شجعان بل
لأنها اللحظة المناسبة  حيث
تشعر بالأمان والثقة ، لقد كنت محظوظًا جدًا ، فقد
قابلت امرأة من حياتي
وساعدتني في التخلص من كل تلك
الذكورة السامة وفتح نفسي
لأننا بالطريقة التي حدث بها كنا
نشاهد
برنامجًا تلفزيونيًا عن الاستغلال الجنسي للأطفال  وهي ترى
وجهي فقط  صدفة وقالت
ما الأمر ، أنا
لا أقول شيئًا ، لكن يا رب أنت تعرف ،
أنا أعرفك جيدًا ، أنت
شخص كريم ولكن عندما تغضب ، يمكنني
أن أشعر بشيء عميق في الداخل حتى
لا نكذب بين بعضنا البعض
ثم
أنا  افتح نفسي ثم أتحدث ثم
أبكي وهذا هو السبب بعد أن تمكنت أيضًا من
التحدث عن ذلك في كتابي ، لذا
لا ينبغي لنا ألا نحكم على هؤلاء
الأشخاص أو نقول إنهم جبناء أو هذا
أنا لأنني حقًا  صعب مع
نفسي ولا أكون شجاعًا ، كما لو
أنني أشعر بالأمان ، أشعر أنني أستطيع الوثوق
بشخص ما وكانت هذه هي اللحظة ، والآن لن
أدفع أي شخص للتحدث عنه ، سأقول
إنك ستحصل على الدعم
لأنه حقًا  من السهل الانفتاح ولكن
هذا هو الدعم التالي ، وهذا هو السبب في أن هذا
سيكون قضيتي بعد لعب كرة القدم ،
فلدي الأولوية للمساواة
بين الجنسين بين الأطفال
والأعراق والصحة العقلية ، كل
هذه الأشياء مهمة حقًا بالنسبة لي.
العيش بعيدًا عن تلك
المدرسة التي كنتِ فيها  كان لاعب كرة قدم طموحًا في
ذلك الوقت تمامًا في تلك المدرسة ،
فقد ترغب في أن
تكون متعلمًا وبعد المدرسة يلعب
كرة القدم ، لم يكن ناديًا لكرة القدم في الأكاديمية
وكان ذلك المعلم يعيش
داخل المدرسة ، لذلك في
كل مرة كنت أستقل القطار
الخامسة صباحًا  فقد أشيائي ، لذا قال
أنك تعلم أن لدي حلًا ، فأنت دائمًا ما
تتعب ، يجب عليك البقاء في المنزل ،
واو ، لقد كانت هذه فرصة
رائعة ، لذلك كان يطبخ الطعام
كل
يوم ، دعني ألعب بعض ألعاب الفيديو
عندما كنت أذهب إلى الفراش ، هذا هو المكان
يبدأ الكابوس
عندما كان يحاول كل ليلة أن يلمسني
وفعلت كل ما في وسعي
للقتال معه ، لكن حتى عندما كنت
أقاتل معه ، كان بجوار السرير
الذي تعلم أنه يساعد نفسه حتى
أنني أتذكر حذائي  أربطة لتشديد بيجامة الخاص بي ،
ثم في
يوم من الأيام
تنجح وذهبت إلى المنزل ، قلت لأمي ،
أنت تعلم أنني لا أريد أن أنام بعد الآن
في منزل كبير المدرسين ، قالت
لماذا باتت تعرف
ولم أرد عليها أبدًا.
قلت لا ، أنا فقط لا أريدها فقالت
حسنًا
لهذا السبب كانت محطمة للغاية عندما
أخبرتها بذلك لأنها كانت
تبكي وتشعر بالذنب وقلت لا
أمي ، هذا ليس عنك وكان
مثلها ولكني أخبرتك
أيها  السبب وأنت لم تقل شيئًا
لأنك لا تستطيع التحدث عندما تحدث هذه الأشياء ،
فأنت فقط تمحو كل
شيء لذاكرتك ، سألني شخص ما سؤالًا
هل تكره هذا الشخص ،
وأقول لا ، هل تريد أن يكون هذا الشخص
في السجن أم أقول  لا وبعد أن أقول لا
نعم
لأنني لا أريد أن يفعل هذا
الشخص نفس الأشياء التي فعلها معي للأطفال الآخرين
[موسيقى]